THIS!
CHANGES!
EVERYTHING!
The One Piece manga just started the MOST
HYPED FLASHBACK because for the very first
time we learn what actually happened on the
legendary island God Valley.
And wow, Oda really knows how to take everything
that we thought we knew and throw it right
in the trash.
Because this island is INSANE and ABSOLUTELY
changes everything we thought we knew about
the legendary battle between the former pirate
king Gol D. Roger and the infamous pirate
Rocks D. Xebec.
But that is FAR FROM the only incredible reveal
in this chapter because we also learned that
the Celestial Dragons are hands down the most
scum-bag group of characters I have EVER SEEN
in any STORY, and even Shanks’ Dad or Uncle,
whoever this guy is, is just as bad as the
rest of them.
Then there’s the possibility that we JUST
MET LUFFY’S MOM!!!
What’s just as crazy though is that we finally
learned EXACTLY what is so special about Bartholomew
Kuma’s race, where Kuma might have gotten
his incredible devil fruit, and how his lineage
directly ties back to Nika from the distant
past.
And speaking of the past, we saw more of Saint
Saturn’s mind-blowing abilities, which are
super powerful and seem to break all sorts
of rules, and I honestly have so many questions
about his mysterious powers.
And let’s start with Saint Saturn because
he showed off some truly unbelievable powers
right at the start of the chapter.
First, he brushed off having a sword stabbed
into his chest like it was nothing.
And not only that, but the blood disappeared
as if nothing had even happened at all.
Like, what???
We’ve only seen one devil fruit in the entire
story that lets you heal yourself, so if Saturn
has some sort of healing powers, that instantly
makes him a HUGE THREAT.
I have to wonder though, is this ability because
of his demon transformation?
Which again to be clear, we still don’t
know if this is an actual devil fruit or if
he is truly just some sort of demon creature.
But the fact that Vegapunk just clearly shouts
out that it must be a devil fruit power makes
me kinda think that it is more likely than
not that he is just straight up a devil.
Man, I’m getting chills just thinking about
the fact that we are finally getting to see
this guy in action.
But I do have an idea about a potential weakness,
which we’ll discuss in just a moment.
Before we get distracted though, Saturn’s
healing was just the first ability he showed
off, because then he busted out his evil looking
eye powers to damage both Bonney and Sanji.
And while I’m still not too clear what this
power is, it seems like this is some sort
of special projectile attack.
Maybe like an invisible haki bullet or just
some kind of demonic ability.
Whatever it is though, it is insanely powerful
because it actually drew blood from both Bonney,
and more impressively, Sanji.
Which is a massive feat because remember that
Sanji’s body is now ridiculously powerful.
I mean he tanked this massive sword from Kaido’s
second commander and even this full force
attack from the overpowered Seraphim without
even flinching.
So just making Sanji bleed shows just the
raw power of even this basic attack from Saint
Saturn.
Now, at this point I was hoping Sanji might
stand a chance against Saturn, but I was dead
wrong because just moments later Saturn somehow
freezes everyone with his mysterious powers.
Which is just like wow, how is he doing this?
These are powerful fighters too, but they
are literally helpless against the Celestial
Dragon.
And now I’m wondering, can Saturn even be
killed?
I mean later on in the chapter we seem to
get even more evidence for the “Gorosei
are immortal theory” because during the
flashback at God Valley, which we’ll break
down in just a moment, he basically looked
unchanged from that time to now.
And I know people in the One Piece world usually
live a lot longer than real life, but come
on!
Thirty-eight years is a pretty long time to
not look any different at all.
So I think we’re once again on the side
of “the Gorosei are immortal beings”.
That doesn’t mean they can’t be killed
though, and Saturn’s comment from the last
chapter about not coming down to the surface
in a long time makes me wonder if they don’t
come down from Mary Geoise because of one
particular weakness.
And that would of course be the sea, which
is basically the enemy of all devil fruit
users.
So assuming he has a devil fruit or that his
devil form is also considered an enemy of
the sea, forcing Saturn into the ocean could
be one way to kill him.
It is certainly possible, and after Saturn
straight up told Kizaru that he was a disappointment,
I’m wondering if we could see the admiral
pick up his boss and just dump him in the
ocean.
Just a theory, but with all the set up of
Kizaru being a slave, I would love to see
him break those chains and take out Saint
Saturn.
But speaking of slaves, let's discuss the
MIND-BLOWING TRUE NATURE of God Valley.
Now, there are three MAJOR CHANGES that we
just have to talk about.
The first is: What is God Valley?
Second, the characters involved in this epic
and also tragic event.
And the third is about one particular little
red-haired kid.
Let’s kick it off with, what even is this
place?
Because ever since chapter 1057 when Sengoku
revealed the legendary battle between the
pirate king Gol D. Roger and the famous pirate
Rocks D. Xebec took place at God Valley, I
think pretty much everyone assumed that God
Valley was some sort of home island for the
Celestial Dragons.
But NOPE!
WE WERE ALL WRONG!
Turns out this island was its own kingdom
that happened to offend the world government.
So because of this, it was chosen thirty-eight
years ago to be the site of a bloodthirsty
tournament where a bunch of slaves and the
people who already lived on God Valley are
all hunted down like animals.
Wow, if you didn’t already hate these spacesuit
wearing world nobles, then surely you do now.
But that’s not all we learned because apparently
this slave-hunting tournament used to take
place every three years.
Which, hold on, if they have been doing this
ever since the Void Century 800 years ago,
that would mean they have taken over or eliminated
around 254 islands with this sick tournament,
not including the last 38 years.
I mean sheesh, how is it even possible they
are that evil?
Of course, we don’t know the full story
though, and I’m wondering if they stopped
this tradition after the events of God Valley
because we have not heard of this tournament
before and we also know that God Valley was
essentially wiped off the map.
So it’s possible that whatever happened
here was so awful for the world government
that they decided to never hold the tournament
again.
Plus, Saint Saturn was clearly at God Valley,
but then he said he hadn’t been to the surface
in a long time, so maybe this particular tournament
was the last time he was down on the surface.
But now I just have to know was that catastrophic
event that made them end the tournament.
And we’ll discuss more about that in just
a moment, but first I want to talk about the
main people who we absolutely know were involved
in this event, including a confirmed epic
one on one battle that we never knew about!
And starting with the person who seems to
be the main villain of this flashback, the
holy Knight, Figarland Garling.
In case you forgot, he is this guy, and it
now seems more likely than ever that he is
truly Shanks dad, since they look so incredibly
similar.
Or if not his dad, maybe Shanks uncle or something.
But apart from killing the original king of
God Valley, Garling is expected to be the
champion of this slave-hunt, which we can
assume means that he is clearly the most powerful
of the world nobles participating.
But now that we know his appearance is SO
similar to Shanks’ it puts a whole new context
on this panel right here.
Because while we’ve never really thought
that Shanks gave Whitebeard some scars in
battle, it's possible now that Whitebeard
fought against Garling during the battle on
God Valley.
We know that Whitebeard was present there
because he was a part of the Rocks crew at
that time, so I think there is a very good
chance we could see Garling attacking Whitebeard
when Rocks does eventually attack.
And man, if Garling is giving Whitebeard scars,
then this man is no joke and should be a devastatingly
powerful fighter.
I for one would give anything to see a full
out fight between these two!
However, talking about Rocks brings up the
next interesting point, because you have to
keep in mind that we were told by Sengoku
that the Rocks pirates attacked God Valley
and were only defeated by the combined power
of Roger, and the hero of the marines, Garp.
But now I’m wondering how much of that is
actually true, if any.
Because now that we know that God Valley wasn’t
just the home of Celestial Dragons, we have
to ask: why did Rocks attack God Valley in
the first place?
Was he trying to free the slaves?
Or was this tournament with so many of the
Gorosei in one place just the perfect opportunity
for Rocks to wipe out the world nobles?
Both seem like reasonable options, but why
then would Roger join the fight to stop Rocks?
Surely, Roger would have hated the Celestial
Dragons as well.
And he wouldn’t have stopped them from freeing
the slaves.
So it has to have been something else, right?
Well, there was one other thing we were told
from this chapter, which was that God Valley
was home to some very valuable natural resources.
Now, we weren’t told what that was.
It could be the incredibly rare Sea Stone,
or maybe gold.
Another incredible option is from chapter
434 and the same conversation between Whitebeard
and Shanks where Shanks says he brought some
Whitebeard some wine from his hometown in
the West Blue.
Which is basically now confirmed to be God
Valley, but interestingly Shanks also calls
this wine “Medicinal Water”, or basically
healing water, so what if God Valley is a
place where magical water naturally appeared?
Certainly seems like a solid option, especially
because right after drinking the wine, Whitebeard
gets up and clashes with Shanks.
Seems like some pretty good healing water
if you ask me.
But that’s not even the most interesting
option in my opinion because God Valley might
have been the original home of the devil fruits.
We’ve already speculated in past videos
that Rocks attacked God Valley in order to
take powerful devil fruits, but I think this
whole situation both supports and also somewhat
opposes this theory.
Because first off, if this was where devil
fruits were created, then why wouldn’t the
world government or some other super powerful
force come and take them?
They didn’t seem to have too much trouble
taking over the kingdom for this tournament,
so why not in the past?
So that’s one point against this idea.
On the other hand, we know that Kaido only
got his devil fruit after the battle at God
Valley.
And the same could also be true for Whitebeard,
who as far as we know didn’t have his fruit
before this battle.
Plus after this chapter we know of at least
one more character who could have gotten their
overpowered devil fruits during the battle
of God Valley.
I’m of course talking about Kuma, who might
have found his broken Paw-Paw fruit after
he was released on this island with a bunch
of other slaves to be hunted down by the Celestial
Dragons.
And wow, if anyone predicted this twist then
I hereby name you the king of one piece theories,
because I for one never saw this twist coming.
But that’s just the start of the incredible
reveals we got about Kuma!
Man, I feel like I keep saying that.
Has this really all just been one chapter???
Anyway, first off we learned that Kuma is
from a race of people called the Buccaneers.
If you’re not familiar, this is a term used
to describe pirates who mostly attacked Spanish
colonies in North America during the 17th
century.
Which to me means that this race was likely
connected with the Ancient Kingdom, who were
almost definitely pirates.
We also learned that this race is a mix of
human and giant blood, which is how Kuma came
to have their ridiculous size and strength,
at least compared to normal humans.
I’m also now wondering if this is true of
other freakishly tall humans we’ve seen
all throughout the story like Big Mom and
Whitebeard.
But to further support the idea that the Buccaneer’s
were allies of the Ancient Kingdom, we are
told that the legend of Nika is passed down
through the Buccaneer members and that Kuma
even knew both the name and the SAME EXACT
DRUM RHYTHM that Nika’s heartbeat makes.
So this could be why Kuma was SO DETERMINED
to help Luffy back in Sabaody when he both
saved the crew from Kiazru and protected their
ship during the timeskip.
Man, this chapter is insane.
And we aren’t even done.
Because once the world government learned
that Kuma’s family is a race the world government
hunts down because once they learned Kuma
had the Buccaneer bloodline, his entire family
was enslaved and taken to Mary Geoise.
Which of course led to Kuma’s father and
mother's deaths and Kuma eventually being
thrown into the slave-hunting tournament on
God Valley.
This might not actually have been the worst
thing for him though because this is where
we see him eventually meet up with the future
Revolutionary Army member, Ivankov, and a
brand new character named Ginny.
And okay, let’s take a deep breath here
because wow, this is just even more fuel for
speculation.
This moment right here could very well be
the origin of the Revolutionary Army.
Which means that Luffy’s father, Dragon,
might also be showing up on God Valley very
soon.
Just, yeah, let’s just keep pouring more
gas onto this chaotic fire.
However, I for one am super curious about
Ginny and the insane possibility that she
could be Luffy’s mom.
I mean, you might think it’s crazy, but
look, she is literally eating meat.
If that is not solid evidence that this is
Luffy’s mom, I don’t know what is.
Oh man, my head is going to explode right
now.
Though if this is Luffy’s mom, we probably
won’t be seeing her for very long, since
moms pretty much never survive backstories.
Moving on though, if Kuma did indeed find
his devil fruit on this island, then his ability
to push people across the world would be the
perfect way for them to eventually escape
the all out war that is coming to the island
very soon.
Before we completely dive off the deep end
though, there is even more to discuss, because
while we brought up Garling’s presence on
this island, there is one piece to all this
that is just incredibly strange.
That’s because we were told that Roger picked
up baby Shanks from a treasure chest.
So if this wasn’t actually Garling’s home,
then why was Shanks here?
Was Shanks’ mom also here?
Or did Garling have Shanks with him?
Did Roger just randomly steal some treasure
and Shanks just happened to be in a chest
like Uta from film Red?
Or did someone like Garp find Shanks and give
him to Roger for protection?
Which would be fitting since it is the exact
inverse of when Roger asked Garp to look out
for Ace after he turned himself into the marines.
And this could completely change how we think
of Shanks, his future role in the story, and
even his mysterious meeting with the Gorosei,
and if you want to know everything about the
story of Shanks so far, you can watch this
video right here.
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.